How could someone have elevated iron levels, but low,
hematocrit, low hemoglobin, and other sides of edemia?
I thought if you had edemia, your iron would be low too.
Well, most of the time, yes, iron deficiency edemia is called iron deficiency edemia because
you have a deficiency in iron. And I did put up a blog post and I think I did put
it up on the member site, some telltale signs of edemia on a general blood test.
But this is a little bit of a twist that is interesting. A person could have all signs of edemia,
low hemoglobin, low hematocrit, low red blood cells, elevated,
low hemoglobin, low hemoglobin, low hemoglobin, low hemoglobin,
low hemoglobin, low hemoglobin, low hemoglobin, low hemoglobin, low hemoglobin,
which would be all signs of edemia, but they could have this twist of elevated iron.
So, your iron that this person is talking about is what's called serum iron.
When you do a blood test, they're measuring your blood level of iron. Serum iron is
is traveling around in your blood bound to a protein called transform.
So, it's bound in your blood and it's carried about in your blood when you absorb it. Now,
most iron that you take in through your food is absorbed in your first part of your small intestine.
And it is necessary for you to have good hydrochloric acid in order for you to absorb iron.
So, one side of low one issue with a person with low iron would could be a decreased
hydrochloric acid content to their stomach, but why would a person have elevated iron?
So, the first thing you think of with elevated iron is a condition called hemicromatosis.
Now, that's a genetic condition. And you think a genetic condition is always going to be
diagnosed with a person as young, but that's not true, because you could have a mild form of hemicromatosis
and you never knew it. And you didn't get this diagnosed until you were 60 years old. You started
to get blood tests for some other reason. You could also have hemociderosis, which is more of
an acute elevation of iron and iron overload. Now, the treatment for elevated iron, when you don't
have other signs of anemia, that's what this question is about, they have other signs of anemia,
the treatment for hemicromatosis would be actually going to giving blood, donating blood on a monthly
basis. But when a person has elevated iron, but then other signs of anemia of their blood work,
it start thinking of it's not hemicromatosis, it's an iron conversion issue. So, they're not
converted iron in their blood. So, it's being stuck in their blood and they're not getting it
to their to their tissues. So, that's a different issue. Now, that can actually be part
of a B12 deficiency or a B6 deficiency. So, there can be other issues with that. So, when a person
has elevated iron, but all other signs of anemia, they still have anemia, but they have an iron
conversion problem. So, the serum iron, being elevated with a decreased red blood cell,
decreased hemoglobin, hematocrit, and other signs is the inability of ends of body to convert
the inner-ganic type of iron found in the serum found to transfer it into the organic hemoglobin
necessary to be carried out throughout the body. So, it's probably a need for vitamin B12,
maybe even folate B6, and if you didn't have cancer, I'd say copper as well. So, but those are the
things that you'd look at with elevated iron and then all signs of anemia.